why can't you get a job well there are
thousands of jobs out there if you're
looking for work you've heard it time
and time again but there are a lot of
people saying despite all the help
wanted ads they are still running into
issues getting a job
joe moeller spoke to some job seekers
who shared their frustrations
while more jobs are popping up around
las vegas some people are still holding
out for those positions
that they know i actually have to wait
for them to call me a barbara brighton
is a joan rivers impersonator
finding a job in the entertainment
capital of the world is still not easy
for her she says as
wonderful as as it is that las vegas has
opened up
it's not completely open for everybody
she says her industry is still slow to
recover and she only has shows booked
for the fall
she continues to receive unemployment
benefits as bookings are hard to come by
it's almost finished we have two more
months thank god for the extension
others are in similar situations while
she knows there are jobs out there
she is holding out for what she knows
how to do i know restaurants still
need a lot of people to come in and work
but i'm not privy to that because
i don't know about that
melissa taylor worked at a coffee shop
at the mccarran airport putting all this
effort
into looking for a job and
there's still i don't get any calls back
finding a job with flexibility for her
family has
not been easy i'm just not getting any
calls back and then
like i said it's just even if i did i
still wouldn't know what i would do with
my kids
with unemployment benefits soon coming
to an end both brighton and taylor say
they will continue to search for
positions
that both will work for them reporting
on the strip joe muller 8 news now
joe thank you the pandemic created a
number of problems for employers and
workers and we are taking a deeper look
at the issues from hiring to
older workers retraining adapting to
remote work and
hot jobs post pandemic those stories
will be at 8 news now
next week